all righty team white
let's try Defour this time last time its
efore Carroll con Panna Botvinnik now
we're gonna have now let's go with this
the Levitsky attack right here instead
of d5 it's the trump popskyy Levitsky
attack ECL code is D zero zero for those
of you that like to look it up like that
let me just take and be assured of the
pawn structure so now I won't be having
to worry about e5 will I sell if any if
there's a strike at this it's coming
with c5 I like this I think just support
my pond yep support my pond and look
into c4 now did I play King's attacker
before with this line I might've hmm let
me get this in a knight c3 may seem a
bit weird to be opening up the position
like this because I don't have the
bishop pair but I'd like to overtake the
only pawn that black has in the center
so let me put more pressure on it did
twice defended once there is no way to
pick that night off with like Bishop
check the Knights guard and yet clean
check the night can be retreating so
what to do with this situation does
black cave in and just take allow me to
recapture and develop it might be okay
do I want to push forward here and kick
this bishop back
hmm I actually wonder about that there
might be something to it a knee-jerk
type of reaction to a c5 move like this
would be well for initially the bishop
backing up to meet the threat boom
shortly thereafter some a five strike at
d4 but maybe there's something with c5
b4 b5 expansion looking to play on the
Queen side I might want to do that let's
give it a shot
let's give this one a go why not
let's get developed Knights are up
classically where does my bishop want to
live here seems good I could eventually
gain a tempo with Queen c2 right now
this pawn is unprotected attacked once
defended once I as I'm viewing it as
unprotected
I'm saw that video devoted a video to
that small concept anyhow Queen c2
castle b4 a 4 B 5 right here if you're
seeing well I have a space advantage on
the Queen side so I'd like to have a
this guy right here wants to have a
buddy right beside I'm right here this
pawn wants to be here
I don't think that there's any hurry
should I castle I just run with it right
away I'm gonna castle let's go I think
if an f5 move as well there it is
it's Knight is on a he's a he's ready to
play into this square which is gonna be
a bit annoying I mean let me see if I
could induce a weakness first g6
I think in research I was thinking about
a g3 move but I think that's too
weakening g3 to just stop this f4 push
but I think that I think g6 needs to be
played here clean here interferes with
this night's journey okay so I don't
have to worry about the night coming
here but if this pawn pushes I think I
just follow up with this move so I'm not
gonna do this I'm not gonna do this in
fact I'll try and show that this Bishop
is maybe out of play
if the pawn plays to f4 I could be going
with E form and if the pawn is not
taking maybe then push here now usually
I'd want to go with a 4 and b5 but I
have enough support for it right now so
I probably should not hesitate with just
going for this right away in fact since
black did not take the time to play a 6
to be preventing this b5 move what could
eventually occur is that this pawn on a7
becomes a liability you know what I'm
talking about after a 6 I have to play a
4 and then after b5 there's chop chop
there's no way pawn to be having to
babysit could turn out to be a problem a
rook once placed on let's say the
seventh would be hitting not only the
bishop at the pawn and who knows
whatever else there's a lot of stuff
here seven pieces 7 ponds and pieces on
that 7th rank it's why they call the
rook a pig he gets hungry he eats a lot
of pieces potentially so here it is here
it is this is what I was talking about
let's go I do not want this Bishop to be
seeing h2 directly now this Knight is a
little bit uncomfortable but maybe this
Queen is going to be uncomfortable as
well because after I take here I think
there's gonna be some issues if I take
over my Bishop I'm trying to win a pawn
but I don't know if I really want to go
pawn grabbing but wait a second if I
take here I'm hitting both pawn and c6 I
don't know if I want to allow this
Bishop to take up
since on that d5 square I take with the
night I'm hitting the Queen the Queen
will likely play here or no maybe h6
Knight takes Queen h6 Knight here
hitting the bishop mmm I don't like this
Bishop coming out here how about Bishop
takes and then something with the push
in the center I think I might be liking
that best you know what actually if I
take here there might be Bishop here
hang on let me go with something more
forceful it's easier to calculate okay
there goes the Queen there goes the
Queen okay now I'm gonna go after that
Bishop I think he's a he's a giant pest
and I don't want to have to deal with
the pest ah Bishop here maybe I could
just do this I want to get rid of the
LightSquared Bishop I would like to have
a pair of Knights off the board if we
could have if I could exchange both of
these Knights for this knight in this
Bishop I think I would I'd be really
happy starting to become a little bit
happier now about because I don't have
to worry about that light square bishop
anymore so let me get rid of him and let
me just take here and let me do what
else I might want to do this move just
to stop that
okay I'm gonna do it clean is kind of
running out of squares I think that
might be an important one to just stop
like let's just stop the nonsense all
together can we just do that let's play
here stop night before also seventh
reading stuff I don't know that's this
night is gonna bother me if this pun
black would much rather not even have
this F for upon it's being a very
disruptive to three pieces four pieces
right here I don't think there's gonna
be a better spot for that rook I need to
get this guy working a minute versus
about forty five ticks okay there's that
a pond that I could be taking I'm gonna
do something more forceful though right
here threatening to get that night and
then the bishop okay now I'm gonna go
here I'm hitting the bishop again
fifteen to thirty and I think it's
actually beat there's no saving this
bishop now it's it's very restricted
there's okay yeah this is dropping now
that Aleta made if there's rook takes so
this pawn for sure really acted as a big
defender of my own Kings side I have a
past C pawn this Knight is gluing
everything together here I just want to
move my bishop away and then push my C
pawn okay so we had a time issue right
there alright could gain king's attack
here let's back up and see how either
one of us could have improved so the
Levitsky I've seen forget who covered it
in the video I think it I forget who it
was let's see all right well after this
capture the Jeep on could of course
still be capturing with in and then
there's still this possibility for
and maybe maybe this is still okay but I
think the Queen move right here there's
an adjustment for that I think I'm
assuming that blacks idea was to get
that night into e4 and I think following
through with that idea is still best I
was a little bit happy to be seeing
Queen f6 because the knight can't play
here so maybe just g6 and then follow up
with the Knight f6 to e4 also I think
it's worthwhile to make white when it
comes time on the Queen side expansion
right here instead of the king move yeah
well in the game I ended up winning a
piece but you'll know that I could also
made to be winning upon in many
variations so again taking this pawn
into account I think at this point right
here you should first play a six and
make me work one move harder to get the
b5 move in so play a six this is
something I had to experience firsthand
because I was that happened to me in an
over the board game and okay I learned
from it I was like well what if I could
have just gotten rid of my a pawn
somehow because it turned out to be a
liability so anyhow a six maybe and I'm
thinking just g6 Knight f6 94 as a
better try I think things start to be
pretty good here
is there something crazy like there's
got to be some I mean it's a slow there
it's slow and strut steady progress over
here on the Queen side if black doesn't
do something quick on the Kings side I
think everything is going to turn out to
be okay and I think this pawn push is
now the last
the last wat this this turns out to be
an issue he gets in the way of all the
black pieces so I had I had a good
response with E for after f4 e for I
think is the correct response so anyhow
I think it's the night that should be
going for this
efore square and try and prevent that b5
moon with a six so all right those just
some quick points good game